Christina Hall battling Mercury and lead
poisoning and she says her job may have
played a part in it Flip or Flop I'm so
lucky I have the best job on the planet
I love my job I love going to work after
years of working on construction sites
Christina's finding herself with some
health issues on Thursday the HGTV star
shared the results of a recent scan on
Instagram writing my scan said I have
mercury and lead poisoning most likely
from all the gross houses I've been in
the bat flips and I have small intestine
bacteria overgrowth so we are first
detoxing all of this through herbs and
IVs
wow oh gosh oh this is seriously
disgusting it smells horrific in here
OMG I'm gonna have to throw away my
shoes is that the kitchen it's the
kitchen oh looks like someone died in
there yeah Christina's flipped many
homes like that on Flip or Flop but she
initially didn't have suspicions that
her work may be the root of her health
concerns instead she went in to find out
if her breast implants were making her
sick she also shared that she got her
lip fillers dissolved and listed several
other ailments she's been battling
including Hashimoto's disease which is a
thyroid condition unexplained skin
rashes joint and muscle pain and more I
kind of just have a consistent healthy
lifestyle you know I've always just
eaten really clean organic one of my
best friends was a nutritionist so I
have that going for me but even amid the
health struggle Christina's still hard
at work we're actually doing a flip out
here in Tennessee right now our first
one
incredible how's it going uh it oh it's
going you'll see it is it on schedule
well we were just beginning so it's
going to be in Christine in the country
Josh and I found this property through a
client of ours that were doing a design
for his house he's a real estate agent
on it and it's bad it's probably like
equal to one of the worst like top five
Flip or Flop houses no yeah
yeah oh you'll have to tune in I cannot
wait for this like the uglier the better
I agree I'm right there with you it was
like this high in debris like I had to
wear my highest biggest boots
[Music]